cannes et ces événements avec ce
vendredi des retrouvailles sur les
marches du festival de stars de légende
claudia cardinale et et alain delon vont
découvrir avec le public une version
restaurée du guépard de luchino visconti
palme d'or en 1963 et nous avons la
chance d'être avec eux ce soir bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous tout d'abord
honneur à vous claudia cardinale je sais
que vous n'êtes jamais perdu de vue
finalement avec alain delon
c'est une vraie belle histoire d'amitié
entre vous absolument moi j'adore alain
on se voit souvent et et c'est
extraordinaire corps est ce qu'on se
connaît depuis pas mal de temps quand
même
alors alain delon on a vu ce matin dans
la presse cette photo tirée du film le
guépard ou claudia cardinale à sa main
et sajoo poser sur votre épaule ce soir
il y aura forcément aller beaucoup
d'émotion de vous retrouver côte à côte
pour ce rendez vous ce serait une grande
émotion parce que parce que ya longtemps
que je n'ai plus fulfilment plus et on
va le revoir remastérisée est il grand
l'émotion suivent parce que je vais
monter les marches avec claudia et que
et surtout la plus grande émotion c'est
parce que nous allons tous les bus
rendre hommage à tous nos amis de ce
film qui sont partis je suis très au
fait de l'embargo louise conti burt
lancaster pierre reggiani et beaucoup
d'autres et que ce sont des gens qui
nous ont tellement 1 alors connaissant
soit leur insu à porter donné beaucoup
de choses hein claudia - je pense le 47
ans après la palme d'or nous nous
devions d'être là juste leur mémoire
justement pour eux il y à 47 ans quelle
était l'atmosphère sur ce tournage avec
luchino visconti de la rigueur du
travail de l'exigence aussi beaucoup
vous avez tout dit rigueur travail
exigeant c'est pas 47 ans et 48 parce
que ses 47 ans la palme d'or mais 48 ans
nous avons tourné en 42 le film alors on
va je sais c'était quelqu'un de qui nous
aimait beaucoup en plus on va juste
quelques quelques unes
j'ai exclusive de cette version
restaurée on va vous retrouver regardons
quelques images ont chaud pour tout
juste après
m
alors alain delon je crois que vous
n'aimez pas finalement revoir ces images
ces films vous les regardez plus jamais
non je voulais encore citer bien sûr la
musique de nino rota qui a fait aussi
l'objet que le plein soleil non je ne
regarde jamais ces images parce que je
fais chaque film est une tranche de vie
et le guépard on était une tranche
exceptionnelle et comme pratiquement que
vous deviez le sait tout le monde est
parti j'ai du mal à revoir ces scènes où
ces gens que j'aimais revivre avec moi
nos côtés et ça m'est insupportable
ça devait pas seulement évidemment pour
le guépard c'est valable pour la piscine
avec romy fait des images que je ne peux
pas voir voilà alors claudia cardinale
bouge chez vous qu'est-ce qui domine
finalement la nostalgie également où
finalement le temps passe et puis c'est
la vie c'est comme ça non le temps passé
la nuit on peut pas faire mais arrêter
le temps bien sûr on a dans notre
mémoire toutes ces rencontres
extraordinaires et comme disait alain
des fois c'est un peu triste de voir que
les autres sont plus là quoi c'est c'est
vraiment dur mais enfin céder les
parties de notre vie quoique il reste
toujours à l'intérieur de nous frapper
vrai ce que vous savez très bien laurent
c'est que avant le départ claudia et
moins nous étions rencontrés dans rocco
et ses frères savait pas rien c'est
aussi un grand chalet qualifia fait à
l'opposé évidemment avec annie girardot
et même après le bateau reste plus qu'à
l'opposé évidemment du départ mais le
guépard effet mettre au 12e grande
rencontre
et oui en tout cas sachez que la
nouvelle génération continue d'avoir en
tout cas un joli regard sur tous ses
films merci à vous passer une très très
belle soirée à cannes
et puis à très bientôt merci la rue bien
suivi pendant un séjour dit merci
voilà pour cette unité à vue réalisées
avant la montée des marches en reste